hi folks not a huge video this week just
wanted to take some time to clear up
some of the misconceptions or
controversy surrounding the george
zimmerman trial notably starting with
rachel the star witnesses comments let's
go to this one first describing the
person is what made you think it was
racial yes and that's because he
described him as a creepy ass cracker
yes so it was racial but it was because
Trayvon Martin put race in this you
don't think that's a racial comment no
[Music]
you don't think that creepy ass cracker
is a racial comment no no a lot of
people and tried to misconstrue the term
creepy ass cracker as something
offensive or or racially charged firstly
I would note that it's it's creepy ass I
believe originally it was creepy ass
cracker that's what was use not cracker
and there is a notable difference
secondly let's drop the PC facade here
creepy ass cracker has been a term of
endearment used among white folk for
years okay who among us is not referred
to a family member as creepy ass cracker
you go to a barbecue its hey there's
uncle Scott you creepy ass cracker oh
you're my favorite nephew creepy ass
cracker that's one for you creepy ass
cracker so let's just be honest about it
and stop trying to feign offense we use
it all the time but the next comment
that she did make it could be a little
more problematic
[Music]
now initially that could seem offensive
especially considering how many
conservatives have been treated for
using that word like an cult or notable
politicians but I understand in this
instance it's it's different because
according to the records the the star
witness Rachel as you've seen would
appear to be a special needs person and
and so she can use the word she can say
that something is [ __ ] see you and I
can't use the word
but only people with special needs can
call each other
[ __ ] they can use the word and I
noticed some people out there you're
saying well Steven your hypocritical
you're breaking your own rule you just
use the word [ __ ] but in my instance
it's it's okay I have a pass because my
best friend actually is is is gay